LANDING ON OUR FRONT DOOR.
HERE NOW SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
MEMBER OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR, CAN YOU CALL
THE WHITE HOUSE AND MAYBE GET
THEM A MESSAGE ABOUT SOME OF
THESE THINGS I'M ADVISING HIM TO
DO?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS AT
HOME.
SO, HERE'S THE DEAL.
IT'S ONE THING TO HURT PUTIN AND
SHUTTING DOWN NORD STREAM 2
HURTS PUTIN.
IT'S A CASH COW.
A PIPELINE GERMANY TO RUSSIA.
GOES AROUND UKRAINE.
AND IT'S A LOT OF MONEY FOR
PUTIN AND A LOT OF GAS FOR THE
GERMANS.
I'M GLAD THEY'RE SHUTTING THE
DAMN THING DOWN BUT IT DOESN'T
HELP YOU HERE AT HOME.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE LET'S BECOME
ENERGY INDEPENDENT AGAIN.
WHY CAN'T WE OPEN UP KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
LET'S HAVE A VOTE IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE AND PUT DEMOCRATS
ON RECORD THEY WANT TO KEEP THE
PIPELINE SHUT DOWN.
WHY CAN'T WE GO BACK TO
AGGRESSIVE FRACKING AND UN --
WHAT YOU JUST SAID, LIMITATIONS
ON EXPLORING FOR OIL AND GAS
HERE AT HOME.
WE ARE SITTING ON AN ABUNDANCE
OF AMERICAN OWNED OIL AND GAS
AND WE SHOULD BE EXPORTING IT
FOR OUR PURPOSES AND HENNING OUR
ALLIES.
WE SHOULD BE ALL-IN WITH ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE BUT, NO, WE ARE
GETTING OUR ASS KICKED OVERSEAS
AND BIDEN IS GETTING LED AROUND
BY HIS NOSE HERE AT HOME BY THE
LEFT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SECURE OUR
BORDER BECAUSE IT WILL PISS OFF
A.O.C.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DRILL OIL
AND GAS WE OWN.
PUTIN IS KICKING HIS ASS IN THE
UKRAINE.
I WILL TELL YOU, THIS JESSE.
YOU ARE A GOOD GUY.
IF WE GET SCREWED OVER IN
UKRAINE THE WORLD AND LET PUTIN
GET AWAY WITH IT, CHINA IS GOING
INTO TAIWAN AND IRAN IS GOING TO
GET A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
ONE THING DOES LEAD TO THE
OTHER.
>> Jesse: SO WHAT WOULD YOU DO
RIGHT NOW IF YOU WERE SITTING IN
THE WHITE HOUSE YOU?
ARE THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM LOOKS
LIKE HE IS GOING IN HARD ANY DAY
NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> HIRE NEW PEOPLE.
I WOULD OPEN UP KEYSTONE
PRODUCTION TOMORROW.
>> Jesse: IN EUROPE?
>> IN EUROPE?
WHAT WOULD I DO?
I WOULD START EXPORTING
LIQUIFIED NATURAL GAS FROM
AMERICA TO EUROPE.
I WOULD TELL THE EUROPEANS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AFTER PUTIN'S
ASSETS.
LET'S DO SOMETHING NEW.
THE GUY IS THE RICHEST -- ONE OF
THE RICHEST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
BECAUSE HE STEALS THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE BLIND.
LET'S TAKE HIS OLIGARCHS.
ALL OF HIS BUDDIES.
TAKE THEIR RICH APARTMENTS FROM
THEM.
SELL THEIR YACHTS AND PUT THEM
IN JAILING FOR BEING WAR
PROFITEERS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD DO IF I
WERE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES I WOULD DECLARE PUTIN AN
INTERNATIONAL WAR CRIMINAL HE IS
INVADING A NEIGHBORING NATION
THAT SIGNED AN AGREEMENT WITH
RUSSIA IN 1994 TO GIVE THEIR
NUCLEAR STOCKPILE TO UKRAINE
WITH A PROMISE THEY WOULDN'T GET
INVADED.
PUTIN BROKE THAT PROMISE AND HE
NEEDS TO PAY A PRICE PERSONALLY.
I GOLD ALL IN WITH ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
AND I WOULD KICK OUR FRIENDS IN
THE ASS FOR NOT HELPING US IN
EUROPE.
>> Jesse: NOW THAT SOUNDS PRETTY
TOUGH.
AND I RESPECT THAT OPINION.
HOW WOULD YOU COOL THINGS DOWN
THOUGH?
BECAUSE SEIZING APARTMENTS AND
MAKING INTERNATIONAL WAR
CRIMINAL I FEEL LIKE GAS IS
PROBABLY GOING TO HIT $10 A
GALLON IF YOU DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
>> YOU CAN'T COOL THINGS DOWN.
>> Jesse: KEEP THINGS DOWN KEEP
THINGS COOL STATE SIDE?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO WAY IT
DISCONNECT US FROM -- THIS WHOLE
IDEA THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN EUROPE
DOESN'T MATTER TO US, REMEMBER
WORLD WAR I AND WORLD WAR II
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT PUTIN IS
GOING AFTER MORE THAN UKRAINE.
THE UKRAINE IS A DEMOCRACY.
HE IS DISMEMBERING THE
DEMOCRACY.
IS HE GOING TO TAKE THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY OVER.
AND CHINA IS WATCHING WHAT HE IS
DOING.
AND IF TAIWAN FALLS, THAT'S
WHERE ALL THE CHIPS IN THE WORLD
WERE PRETTY MUCH MADE.
CHINA WOULD OWN TAIWAN.
THE IRANIANS I WOULD SPEND THREE
DAYS IN ISRAEL.
THEY ARE WORRIED TO DEATH THAT
BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE THE BACK
BOBBY TO STOP THE AYATOLLAH WHO
WANTS A NUCLEAR BOMB.
HE IS A RELIGIOUS NAZI.
IS HE NOT GETTING A BOMB TO
PROTECT THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
IS HE GETTING A BOMB TO ENACT
HIS RELIGIOUS AGENDA WHICH MEANS
TO KILL ALL THE JEWS AND THE
INFIDELS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO BE NICE
ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH MORE WE
HAVE TO SUFFER AS A NATION AND
LET BAD GUYS KICK US IN THE ASS
AND LOSE CONTROL OF OUR OWN DEN
DESTINY AT HOME.
I DON'T KNOW OF A NICE WAY TO
STAND UP TO THUGS.
>> Jesse: LAST QUESTION REAL
QUICK IF HE GOES AFTER A NATO
COUNTRY, IF DO WE SEND SOLDIERS
THERE AND BAIL OUT ESTONIA OR
LITHUANIA OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
>> WE BETTER BECAUSE WE MADE A
PROMISE TO ALL OF OUR NATO
ALLIES AND AN ATTACK ON ONE IS
AN ATTACK ON ALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND YOU, MY
FRIEND, AFTER 9/11 ARTICLE 5 WAS
INVOKED FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY AND NATO ON OUR BEHALF.
IF YOU LET PUTIN GET AWAY WITH
THIS AND CHINA GET AWAY WITH IT
AND IRAN GET AWAY WITH IT, YOU
WILL BE IN A THIRD WORLD WAR AND
A BUNCH OF RADICAL ISLAMISTS
WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT'S WHY YOU NEED TO CONTROL
YOUR BORDER.
REMEMBER WORLD WAR II.
THIS DIDN'T WORK OUT WELL THEN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK OUT WELL
NOW.
I MISS DONALD TRUMP.
IF DONALD TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT,
NONE OF THIS CRAP WOULD BE GOING
ON BECAUSE YOU HAVE GOT TO BE
STROCK.
WHEN YOU ARE WEAK IS WHEN
EVERYTHING FALLS APART.
AND BIDEN IS WEAK AND TRUMP WAS
STRONG.
I HOPE WE HAVE ANOTHER ELECTION
SOON.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THANK YOU